[Music]
gina carano's cara dune won't return for
future seasons of the pedro pascal led
series the mandalorian or
for any other star wars project for that
matter on wednesday february 10
2021 carano a former mixed martial
artist who has become a recognizable
face in the action and sci-fi genres
over the years was fired from the
mandalorian
as reported by deadline a spokesperson
for lucasfilm confirmed on wednesday
evening that carano wasn't just dropped
from the first ever live-action star
wars series she's also no longer going
to be considered for
or offered employment with lucasfilm in
the future
the decision came after carano continued
to share on social media statements that
lucasfilm deemed quote abhorrent
carano's cara appeared throughout many
episodes of the mandalorian's first
and second seasons aiding pascal's
denjarian on his quest to reunite grogu
aka baby yoda with other jedi originally
audiences were impressed by carano's
introduction into the star wars universe
with many enjoying the strong presence
she brought to the series as a former
rebel shock trooper turned bounty hunter
but the star's penchant for expressing
her political opinions online
no matter how divisive or offensive
those opinions might be caused many fans
to urge
lucasfilm to fire her as deadline
details carano's most recent
controversial post on instagram
suggested that being a republican in the
us in 2021
is similar to being jewish in nazi
germany this sparked renewed outrage
online and hashtag fire gina carano
started trending on twitter as folks
tagged both disney and lucasfilm in
thousands of tweets in an effort to
remove her from the mandalorian
at that point lucasfilm had already
taken note of carano's damaging social
media presence but her post implying
that republicans are being harmed in the
same way
jewish people were harmed in nazi-era
germany was the breaking point
wednesday evening the studio released a
statement announcing her firing
it reads gina carano is not currently
employed by lucasfilm
and there are no plans for her to be in
the future nevertheless her social media
posts denigrating people based on their
cultural and religious identities are
abhorrent and unacceptable
alongside her exit from the star wars
series variety reports that carano was
also dropped by her talent agency
uta due to the offensive nature of the
comments she made online
for several months now fans have been
banding together to call for carano's
firing
carano previously caused controversy in
november 2020 when she mocked social
media users who list their pronouns
such as she her hers or they them theirs
in their bios putting
beep bop boop in her own profile as
noted by variety carano also
seemingly made a mockery of safety
regulations put in place during the
covet 19 pandemic
sharing a photo of someone wearing
several cloth masks over their nose and
mouth
and captioning it meanwhile in
california
carano's most recent posts have since
been deleted from instagram but
screenshots are still circulating across
various social media platforms
sources told the hollywood reporter that
lucasfilm executives had been planning
for about two months to fire carano and
that today was the final straw
the outlet also revealed that lucasfilm
intended to announce a cara dune
spin-off series during the disney
investors day presentation in december
2020
but those plans were abandoned after
chrono took to twitter in early november
to level accusations about voter fraud
in the 2020 u.s presidential election
she wrote in part flush out the fake
votes make voter fraud end in 2020.
there was some support for carano
following the news of her firing as a
number of her supporters started
tweeting
cancel disney plus with disney's
impressive slate of spin-off shows like
ahsoka tano
the acolyte rangers of the new republic
the book of boba fett
and or obi-wan kenobi and lando as well
as
all the marvel studios projects and
development cancelling the streaming
service will certainly miss out on
a lot of new content a fan started a
change.org petition
calling for lucasfilm to keep carano in
the mandalorian the organizer wrote in
part
this is a counter petition to support
gina carano for keeping her role in the
mandalorian
everyone is entitled to an opinion
whether it be right or wrong
many who signed the petition have argued
that chrono's firing is the result of
cancel
culture the change.org petition is
rapidly approaching its goal of 5 000
signatures but
time will only tell if that will
translate into disney plus cancellations
the only question left to ask is whether
lucasfilm will choose to scrap
cara dunes character completely or
recast another actor in the role ahead
of the mandalorian season 3.
for now gina carano is cara dunn with
the star wars universe
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
controversy are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one